tu as his death cuffaut mon ex porte
parole de générations identitaire vient
de porter plainte pour agression
sexuelle s'est glissé des rames en a
plus souvent très jeune femme raconte
avoir été séquestré avant d'être agressé
sexuellement mardi en fin de matinée à
son domicile par un migrants d'origine
tunisienne selon elle c'est simple c'est
lui qui m'a dit je suis resté bloqué une
demi heure avec lui donc j'ai eu le
temps de discuter le parquet de lyon a
annoncé qu'une enquête était en cours
pour retrouver l'auteur des faits cités
il a reçu beaucoup de messages de
soutien sur les réseaux sociaux certains
s'interrogent sur ses déclarations vu
ses prises de position politiques
extrémistes alors qu'elle est déçue font
agresser comprenez vous que certains
doutent de son témoignage à cause de ses
idées et des soupçons étaient avec nous
ce soir pour revenir sur cette affaire
merci d'être avec nous tu as his death
que font 22 ans
déjà est ce que vous comprenez que
certains doutent de votre témoignage à
cause de vos idées ou est-ce que ça ça
ça vous met en rogne je pense que c'est
pour des raisons politiques c'est c'est
de l'intimidation politique avant on
disait que je mentais que j'exagérais
quand je dénonçais le fait que la
majorité des individus qui agressent et
harcèlent des femmes dans la rue étaient
d'origine étrangère ou en tout cas était
d'origine immigrée et maintenant on
disait voilà que j'étais privilégié que
je savais pas de quoi je parlais et puis
maintenant que ça m'arrive on dit que je
mens on va revenir sur la faire vous
allez nous raconter vous avez été
victime d'une agression sexuelle et
d'une séquestration tout commence après
votre séance de sport mardi matin vous
loger chez l'une de vos amis à qui vous
rendez visite mon marché donc dans la
rue vous écoutez de la musique c'est ça
exactement donc je sortais de ma salle
de sport je passe en coude un coup de
fil professionnels devant la porte de
mon ami est en fait tu vas acheter
adossé à la porte j'ai avec mes
écouteurs et jeu du coup j'ai pas
entendu qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui est
arrivé derrière moi probablement sahara
est chaud c'est donc en fait dès que
j'ouvre la porte ya pas de hall d'entrée
je tente j'ouvre la porte du rentrer
dans l'appartement et au moment de
vouloir refermer la porte je vois une
ombre à travers la vitre qui est qui qui
arrive j'avoue que je ne suis pas
imaginer que ça pouvait être un individu
que je connaissais pas je me suis dit
peut-être que c'est mon ami qui revient
je sais pas j'ai en fait je sais pas et
j'ai eu un instant de sidération il et
il est rentré dans mon appartement a
tout de suite pris mon téléphone des
mains que je tenais comme ça parce que
j'écoutais de la musique la vie dans sa
poche a tout de suite fermé la porte a
fermé à clé a pris la clef et il m'a dit
quand vous retrouvez avec l'individu
chez votre ami ouais seules celles ouais
d'accord donc là qu'est ce qui se passe
là tout de suite il me il me dit il me
dit de ne pas faire de me taire il me
dit
t'inquiète pas inquiète pas je je je
dois juste resté dix minutes je vois
juste ces dix minutes ici je suis
poursuivi moi je me demande tout de
suite de me prendre mon téléphone je
répète remontée folle romont téléphone
je veux ça va me dire je suis désolé
chiron désolé je veux je veux pas te
faire peur juste je ne veux pas de faire
de mal je te jure je te jure walla jeu
pas de faire de mal je veux juste je
vais monter je ne veux pas te faire de
mal juste j'ai besoin je suis poursuivi
tu comprends il ya des gens ils sont
violents je comprends rien de ce qu'ils
me racontent
mais en fait je comprend vite que j'ai
pas tellement le choix parce qu'en fait
effectivement pour le moment il est à
distance relativement deux mois ils
montraient pas de signes d'agressivité
de premier abord il a mon téléphone il a
ma clé donc là en fait le seul choix que
j'ai c'est paraître d'attendre et de me
dire je parie sur le fait qu'
effectivement je sais pas il poursuivi
je ne sais pas par qui et qu'au bout de
dix minutes il va partir donc je donc là
qu'est ce qui se passe donc la danse et
voilà vous restez il reste à distance il
reste pour l'instant à distance sont les
bus mais à côté du canapé il me dit tu
vois je te touche pas je ne touche pas
je te jure et où il me répète ça en
millions fois qu'il est désolé que que
c'est pas parce que je suis une femme
qu'il est rentré chez moi qu'il aurait
préféré que ce soit un homme parce que
il aurait soi-disant compris pourquoi il
était poursuivi qui devait se cacher et
après il commence à vouloir essayer de
me mettre à l'aise je sais pas donc une
conversation faussement détendu commence
il me dit à chaque fois c'est une
sportive toi et tout c'est pas parce que
j'avais achetée en affaires de sport
encore et comment ça que je dis oui
donc commence à me dire à moi je faisais
du rugby fin je sais pas quoi il
commence à raconter sa vie me demande
mon prénom
je lui réponds et il me donne le sien
j'avoue que quelque chose comme ramsau
mars à autre chose comme ça et c'est là
que immédiateté française toi non je dis
oui dit ata des origines je dis non
india d'accord au fait la personne dia
moi moi moi je suis tunisien tu vois et
c'est donc jeudi avant ça fait un an et
demi que je suis en france effectivement
il parlait pas exact enfin il y avait
des mots vocabulaire qui lui manquait
mais bon il parlait relativement bien
français quand même mais avec un fort
accent quand même et est donc il me dit
il me dit qu'il est d'origine tunisienne
que ça fait un an et demi qu'il est en
france qu avant ils tant en allemagne
enfin voila il demande à boire à un
moment
donc je jallet m'exécuter est en fait il
dit à attends tu comprends et two way
nom signifie pas j'ai pas confiance
c'est tout je vois bien t'es gentil mais
mais tu comprends j'ai peur pour les
traces et tout donc jamais vivant ça que
ça veut dire et donc en fait
effectivement il ne fallait pas laisser
de traces d adn chez moi donc je
commençais j'avais peur mais c'est vrai
que ça m'a été encore moins à l'aise je
fini quand même par lui servir un verre
d'eau en espérant que
j'ai pas que j'aurais pas là mais bon
est en fait j'ai dû de laver sous ses
yeux
il m'a demandé également s'il pouvait
fumer début je me suis ravisé ce que par
réflexe je savais que ma mon ami m par
la fumée de cigarette chez elle après
coup je me suis dit mais en fait si
jamais il laisse son mégot tu vas
pouvoir avoir des traces adn donc du
coup je lui dis en fait si finalement tu
peux fumer donc il remercie ses gentils
et où ils sont à l'affût mais moi je
suis tout faut savoir que tout ce temps
là je me tient à distance de lui il a
toujours mon téléphone il ya toujours
mes clés je je je me dis je sais pas je
me dis que tant que je reste la statique
à distance voilà c'était encore une
chance de m'en sortir
vous avez peur vous vous sentez en
sécurité
dans l'instant il reste à distance
salaires des lycées qui se passe quand
même temps là alors en tout ça a duré
une demi heure ça mais l'assurance mais
là je dirais que ça a duré 25 minutes ça
y est voilà où il a laissé sur les cinq
dernières minutes où il a échoué
régulièrement du coup je regarde ma
montre et je disais bon ça fait dix
minutes maintenant ça te dit que tu
devais repartir jeux testés et c'est
chez moi maintenant est ce que tu veux
me rendre mes clés mon téléphone et
repartir et il disait attendre puisque
orange et en sus cinq minutes de plus
cinq minutes et je te jure je te jure je
pars après je te jure voilà
et donc donc j'attends j'attends
il finit par au bout d'un moment me dire
ah bon je vais pas t'embêter plus
longtemps je m'en vais
et il me dit par contre faut qu'une
toile à table d'abord donc je prends le
cendrier je prends les chez great gig
oui bien sûr je vais à la cuisine jeux
lettre les mégots de cigarettes dans la
poubelle je lave le cendrier sous ses
yeux et en fait je vois qu'ils
récupèrent les mégots au fond de la
poubelle et qu'il me et qui me dira si
j'ai désolé tu comprends ce pas j'ai pas
confiance mais je suis parano et tout
donc j'ai bon pas de problème
et donc c'est en fait c'est en se
rapprochant de la porte il faut savoir
qu'au fil de la conversation il avait
commencé à me poser des questions plus
personnelles et ce que je sais ce que tu
as un copain
ttc joly la vérité si j'avais une femme
comme quoi je serais heureux j'avais une
femme comme temps en allemagne et tout
avec sa famille c'était compliqué fin
raconté samedi
et donc donc j'avoue que j'avais mais
pas trop la tournure que prenait la
conversation puisque il m'assure et
surtout les surtout il radieux que si
vous voulez pas de mal mais commence à
parler de mon physique de 2 voilà de mon
ma vie privée et donc je me rapproche je
me rapproche de la porte il a posé mon
téléphone sur le canapé ou bien tu vois
je te rends fonds téléphone et où il
s'approche et ils sont la clé il
s'apprête à la mer il fallut là mais
dans la serrure mais il est encore
devant la porte moi je suis pas et il me
dit juste juste avant de partir tu as
vraiment été gentil avec moi est ce que
tu veux bien me faire un bisou et là
jusqu'à maintenant j'étais resté calme
mais là je commence à vraiment avoir le
stress qui monte pas ce que je dis ça
tourne pas bien du tout cette histoire
donc donc du coup je commence à dire non
non non non je suis désolé j'ai été
gentil avec moi tout cela j'ai fait tout
ce que tu voulais maman s'il te plait je
veux que tu partes je n'ai pas appelé la
police comme tu m'as demandé j'ai
pas pu la police comme tu m'as demandé
si je suis ce que tu t'en ailles
maintenant voilà est en fait il me prend
par l'avant toit ils essaient de me
forcer à l'endroit c'est je le repousse
le débat j'appelle chapelle je pleure
j'ai dit arrête un axe top jeu va-t'en
va-t'en tu m'avais dit que je partais et
là en fait y avait un coup juste
derrière moi
tiens par les deux poignets il me faire
l'asseoir sur le pouf et il me dit
khantour a comme toi arrête de pleurer
arrête de pleurer et il me dit je veux
juste juste une chose juste une chose
après je m'en vais je te jure je m'en
vais après je te demande juste une chose
est donc voila c'était absolument
terrorisé vous demander voilà
je suis désolé papa maman que j'ai
regardé sur moi l'été à ces mois là
parce que c'est pas agréable d'entendre
ça mais du coup bah je je je le regarde
je suis terrorisée elle a une vie juste
avant de partir juste juste une suce
hélas jamais faire la silhouette plus
belle et j'avais vraiment super peur et
hommes
et donc du coup mais je suis allé en
battant mais tu as pleuré j'ai fait tout
ce que tu m'as demandé manon système les
battants et ses bas il n'y a même plus
ou moins lâché j'aime bien évoluer
pendant
j'ai eu à la porte et il est parti j'ai
pas comment elle fait pour partir parce
que j'étais sûr qu'il allait pas partir
les mais franchement il y avait 1 % de
chances pour qu'il s'en aille
il avait ma clé j'ai pas mon téléphone à
côté de moi il aurait pu se passer
n'importe quoi il aurait pu être armé il
peut y avoir un couteau donc c'est à ce
moment là c'est tout de suite je me suis
précipité sur la porte s'est fermée à
clé je me suis jeté sur mon téléphone et
j'ai tout de suite appelé mon ami en
larmes j'ai attendu qu'elle arrive et
puis finalement j'ai fini par appeler la
police deux heures après qu'eads mieux
je vais me menace lg tout vous raconter
après ils m'ont emmené faire des
positions et ils ont retrouvé la
personne ou pro quoi non pas encore pas
encore alors merci pour ce témoignage
alors c'est vrai que il ya eu un
déferlement ensuite après vous avez sur
les réseaux sociaux et il ya énormément
de gens qui ont mis en doute votre
témoignage à cause de vos idées
politiques et gilles verlant la manière
dont vous raconter le drame qui vous est
arrivé vous avez toute ma solidarité
c'est bouleversant moi ce qui me gêne
c'est la partie quand vous dites il m'a
dit qu'il était tunisien et c'est vrai
que vous en avez fait de ce drame un
fait politique c'est à dire que derrière
tout ça il est tunisien et donc je vous
l'avais dit dites vous c'est un fait
divers liés à l'immigration c'est ce que
voulait signifier politiquement moi ça
me gêne que vous ayez fait de ce drame
épouvantable qui vous est arrivé un fait
politique ce qui me gêne c'est qu'on me
demande d'occulter une partie de la
vérité pour plaire à une bien pensante
et une propagande anti raciste mais
c'est quoi la vérité j'en ai marre mais
la vérité c'est que c'était un des
grands d'origine tunisie alors à cacher
c'est alors la am c'est qu'on gouverne
agressé c'est pas qu'ils soient j'en ai
assez qu'on vient de dire à des femmes
qui se sentent pas en sécurité dans la
rue que qui sont agressés qu'on leur
dise si vous dites l'origine de vos
agresseurs et bien vous êtes vous êtes
des racistes vous n'avez pas le droit ça
se fait pas
caché par rapport à l'origine leur dit
lui même en tout cas il était maghrébin
ça c'est certain et c'est pas si les
maghrébins les argiles et guy mollet
dire c'est ça qui me gêne gilles soulez
et soulève c'est ça qui me gêne chez lui
et c'est vrai c'est après les réseaux
sociaux donc voilà la wii mais
mathieu de l'envié mais vous le bruit
mais vous le voyez comme moi pas pardon
je n'étais pas là je dis juste que le
corps parle plus que les mots chocs au
tennis fit qui tremblent j'ai eu aucun
déroule verser les prêts united après là
j'avais bien ça le tunisien salma elle
raconte il était l'ami vient jamais elle
raconte des faits elle raconte des 50
buts à elles racontent qu'ils
voyageraient complications c'est
impossible elle raconte des faits une
histoire je la tuerais aurait pu dire il
est noir il est blanc leur a pu dire
n'importe quoi elle a décrit une
personne elle a décrit la personne le
prénom et où elle aurait pu dire et
s'appelle michel il était blanc
d'avignon elle a décrit toute l'histoire
avec les mots à aucun moment dans cette
histoire je n'entende raciste et jeunes
votre chose qu'une femme qui est
tremblante entendent raconter une
histoire je ne vois rien d'autre
est-ce que des corps et quand on doit
aller pardon de déposer plainte de la
même manière les gendarmes la police
vous demande bavoil a expliqué nous tous
il était comment c'est tout à fait
normal pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut taire
ça on lui demande qu'est ce qui s'est
passé quelles ont été les dialogues donc
là elle dans sa tête elle doit dire ok
ça je dois pas dire parce que sinon les
gens ils vont penser que c'est un
concours de circonstances c'est horrible
horrible ce qui vous est arrivé et
gilles que tu puisse remettre ça en
cause mais absolument pas remis en cause
le drame est là elle est en
fait mon cas
oui c'est je m'en suis bien sorti j'ai
la chance mais plein de vie plein de
femmes françaises qui n'ont pas la
chance que je sois
tu sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais
il ya à peu près un an j'étais à peu
près assez de place ici sur le plateau
de balances ton post et j'avais 10 ans
et j'avais dit un chiffre j'avais dit
que
% des agressions dans les transports en
commun en ile-de-france était le fait
des étrangers et excusez-moi cyril je
vous remercie de m'avoir invité mais à
ce moment là vous aviez dit que vous
n'aviez si je l'avais pas les chiffres
vous ne croyez pas eh bien les chiffres
rouges les et là c'est le ministère de
la terre vous aviez dit de revenir la
prochaine fois avec la fille des
chiffres c'est long mais c'est
simplement des chiffres les
oui c'est ça le problème c'est ce à quoi
des chiffres c'est les chiffres jeu des
zellers et ministère de l'intérieur
c'est déjà noël 2010 9 63% des
agressions sexuelles dans les transports
en commun sur le fait d'étrangers et je
ne parle même pas des personnes
d'origine
oui pour ça qu'on me reproche
je suis désolé je mets en fait moi mon
témoignage si j'ai décidé d'en parler
c'est que j'en ai assez de ce tabou que
les filles qui auraient pas quoi en
faire renchérit je suis écouté je suis
mais je vous raconte quelque chose qui
m'est arrivé que je ne souhaite à
personne mais aussi toutes les fois où
j'ai été harcelée voir et où on m'a
insulté on m'a manqué de respect c'était
systématiquement tout mon cas des non
blancs et ça c'est en mai ça fait encore
mal à passer
vous n'avez pas le droit de dire ça en
france non mais là c'est jeanne d'arc
est admirée du ratio fans on va là
bas je vous remets pas en doute ce qui
peut t'arriver qui est épouvantable et
vous ne pouvez pas je moi quand je vous
entends parler je pense à tout ce qui se
passe depuis des dizaines d'années on
peut pas montrer les gens une communauté
c'est à cause de ses yeux c'est horrible
de faire ça mais
c'est président noir blanc ou jaune mon
propre que vous ayez été adressées ça
c'est un problème le reste
et vous allez en militante en disant
allez faisons trois garçons c'est moi je
vous dit votre discours je ne peux pas
longtemps et je ne veux plus l'entendre
aujourd'hui voilà je vous l'aï
sincèrement
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien rajouter quelque chose bon je
voulais dire que ça c'est des choses que
vous pouvez dire ici en plateau mais en
fait les français qui regardent la
télévision ce soir et qui vivent dans le
réel qui sont dans le quotidien qui
vivent dans des quartiers pas dans le
6ème pas dans des quartiers riches ils
savent ce que c'est la réalité je suis
désolé mais je suis sûr que toutes les
filles aunès qui côtoient le réel et qui
regardent cette émission aujourd'hui
savent très bien le type de profit des
noms tels compteurs dans la rue et ça
y'en a assez d'emplois mais tendant le
doigt la trace de dire oui à la bien
pensante je suis désolé je suis pas bien
aujourd'hui moi je levais ans le tabou à
l'open d'espagne et kaboul la preuve
vous ne voulez pas que je le dise mais
c'est une vérité géants et des chiffres
à l'appui et aujourd'hui et all inks et
a sorti un rapport avec le service
statistique ministériel de la sécurité
intérieure du ministère de l'intérieur
je voulais très l'assaut sur ma chaîne
télégramme si vous ne me croyez pas les
étrangers représentent 7,6 pour cent de
la population française ils représentent
pourtant 30% des vols violents 28 % des
cambriolages 14% des violences sexuelles
ou encore 18 % des homicides alors voilà
c'est des chiffres c'est factuel mais et
moi mais vous expérience est arrivé à il
se déguise ont tout fait ça c'est fait
seul déjà sortir des chiffres après
cette série c'est ça c'est ça c'est la
jeune femme alors qu'elle soit utile
mais ça se fait agresser sa nièce
politiquement utilisé politiquement
c'est ça la volée la politique vous
savez même gilles c'est d'utiliser
l'effet du quotidien pour en fait
essayer de les régler et moi je n'en
peux plus je ne veux plus avoir peur
pour mes petites soeurs quand elles
sortent de la faculté la nuit je ne veux
pas mais le témoin qui vécut gens
pourraient se plaît géraldine m'a
d'abord je combats vos idées mais je
vous crois voilà d'ailleurs je trouve
qu'il ya un silence assourdissant des
associations féministes qui toujours 10
on est toujours avec les victimes et
tout ça mais quand c'est du mauvais côté
et pas du côté de la bien-pensance qui
sont pas du côté des victimes parce que
vous êtes malgré tout il victime même si
je combats toutes vos idées après moi ce
que j'ai du mal à comprendre dans votre
démarche
malgré tout et c'est compliqué parce que
vous êtes une victime c'est que vous et
sans alizée c'est à dire que vous êtes
tout d'un coup une victime et deux
secondes après il n'y a plus de il ya
plus de stigmates de cette agression et
vous sortez des statistiques est venu
bombardé le truc en dix ans ben voilà
c'est parce que
j'aime et c'est sa deuxième chance non
mais avec les suédois je vous dirai ce
que vous est ce que vous seriez venu sur
ce plateau est ce que vous auriez
parlant le jeu que vous l'auriez fait ce
que vous auriez mis votre votre
procédure doit faire bizarre on dit que
vous l'auriez post et suzie exactement
c'est vrai que je devrais c'est ce que
disent les gens les gens disent on a
l'impression que ça n'arrange qu'ils
soient tunisiens mais en fait c'est bien
sûr mais je condamne toutes les
violences et ses choix une question de
dire que c'est que les violences d'une
certaine partie de la population que je
condamne la réalité c'est que la
majorité de ces agressions dans la rue
et du harcèlement et bien c'est le fait
en majorité de personnes d'origine
immigrée et ça je ne peux rien je suis
désolé vous savez moi pour avoir dit ça
mon compte instagram j'ai été signalés
en masse il a été suspendu donc
effectivement vous c'est bien de dire
que quand on dit certains faits il ya
des associations féministes ben c'est
silence radio a absolument personne ne
s'est exprimé pour soutenir à part des
personnes qui sont ceux de mon bord
policiers qu'il faut le dire et donc
voilà ça c'est silence radio jeu elle
était sûrement trop occupé avec
l'écriture inclusive où les jouets genre
et dans les magasins c'est la réalité
que vivent les françaises dans la rue
c'est c'est ce que moi les mains vous
avez dans un magma oui je n'ai jamais
caché être une activiste politique moi
ya un an j'étais ici pour défendre
génération avait quitté raconte j'ai
connu un porte parole est ce que ce que
je dénonce eh ben j'ai fini par le livre
moi aussi et donc c'est normal en fait
c'est normal que j'utilise ces faits là
pour défendre pour défendre en fait et
toutes les autres filles de france qui
pense que moi et tuant pas l'audience
fait que j'aurai moi aujourd'hui sur ce
château fort et surtout les réseaux
sociaux vous savez j'aurais pas la
chance de dire tout ça tous les jours
évidemment que j'en profite pour dire à
toutes les filles qui se sentent seuls
et qu'ils ont peur de se faire traiter
de raciste si elles disent l'origine de
leurs agresseurs de leur dire que non
elle ne sont pas racistes et qu'elles
ont raison et que les chiffres sont là
pour les appuyer voilà oui après on peut
pas dire que cette agression
vous êtes contente que ce soit un
immigré ou quoi que ce soit si je me
tiens je suis content tu alain bernard
et moi c'est juste que je n'aurais pas
mais moi je comprends que ça renforce
quelque chose voilà vous vous battiez
déjà pour ça il vous arrive ça c'est le
comble forcément ça renforce et vous
êtes là en victime et puis de secondes
après vous pouvez être militant parce
que vous l'avez toujours été c'est la
même chose mais quand je mets et c'est
vrai donc et quand je me suis fait voler
maman de la même manière vous m'avez
demandé de raconter et au bout d'un
moment on raconte et moi aussi bas
forcément ce qui m'a dit je prend
l'accent est tout et je me rappelle
cyril ou m'a dit oui enfin on peut le
faire sans l'accent voilà mais bon et
donc vous avez aussi dit oui au bout
d'un moment il a dit oui à la wii il m'a
parlé de
les victimes racontent est alors bon bah
voilà 6 il ya plusieurs cas comme ça
c'est que c'est comme ça et je trouve ça
très triste de mettre le tabou sur je
suis chez moi quand vous avez porté
plainte d'ailleurs il ya une enquête
ouverte en mai le précise du parquet
d'accord quand vous avez porté plainte
vous avez raconté les faits oui les
policiers entendent les faits oui là
vous avez digéré les faits et vous êtes
venu faire un discours contre
l'immigration contre les tunisiens bien
d'une
version de bouillir une version la
plainte des plaintes geste ils n'en
tirent pas tout ça moi je savais que je
n'avais pas compté dans la plainte le
commissaire j'ai raconté exactement
comme je vous l'aï dit aux commissaires
de police savait ce qu'il m'a répondu
m'a dit oulala ça va être compliqué des
profils comme ça on en a cinq mille donc
si t'es pas un peu plus précise sur le
sur comment il est habillé ses traits et
ses formes est très compliqué mais vous
avez un meeting politique je suis devenu
là où vous l'avez digérer vous venez de
faire sur le plateau pour forcément se
prétendent victimes de bavures
policières est ce que vous les accusez
de récupération politique c'est
exactement la même chose la politique
c'est s'emparer des faits du quotidien
essayer de les régler de trouver une
solution est d'avoir des réponses à ça
pour moi c'est ce que je fais au nom
vous scénarisez la teneur il avait un
ancien lycée alors mais moi vous savez
très bien que je vous l'avait raconté
que j'avais était vieux déboires rentré
j'ai pas dis l'origine mon agresseur et
quand on me l'a demandé j'ai dit basse
et c'était un monsieur maghrébins et on
m'a dit ah bah forcément alors que moi
je n'avais pas dit et je vous rappelle
que j'ai pas porté plainte parce que
quelque part le type le type même le
team j'ai pas voulu lui nuire et là vous
m'avez fracassé en disant vous auriez dû
porter plainte thomas assure une
situation qui était encore plus grave
que la vôtre c'est vrai que moi j'ai
choisi de ne pas dénoncer le mec donc
c'est vrai que je suis c'est sam ça me
gêne mais oui ça veut dire que j'ai pas
théorisé du tout moi pour le coup j'ai
pas théorisé du tour à ce moment là et
ça m'a été reproché aussi yum non mais
ce qui est gênant ses comptes herman on
prend un fait divers et on s'en sert
pour faire la récupération politique à
quoi ça sert de mentionner l'origine de
votre agresseur à quoi ça sert de faire
un amalgame entre ce qui nous est arrivé
non mais vous en met d'accord non mais
dans la manière dont vous le rapportez
non pas ici mais dans ce que vous avez
déclaré sur internet à quoi ça sert de
faire un amalgame entre ce que vous avez
vécu et vos idées politiques d'extrême
droite ça ne sert à rien puisque le
problème c'est que vous n'allez pas
condamner une personne qui en
l'occurrence votre agresseur qui doit
être condamné et vous condamnez des
millions de personnes qui sont d'origine
maghrébine qui ont rien fait de mal et
qui vont encore être associés à des
images de délinquants non mais ça le
violeur et d'agresseurs et c'est
dégueulasse et jamais dit ne savait pas
ridicule je n'ai jamais dit que toutes
les personnes issues de l'immigration
était si la fois juste que vous avez 10
et voila voila c'est pourquoi je me bats
jo rites et des personnes sur la grèce
et harcèlent dans la rue sont d'origine
on vous avait dit qu'à 36 morceaux 14%
de violence sexuelle vous avez dit par
des étrangers dont 86% parlons ici du
ministère de nos vies dont 81 sél à s'en
sortir mon quart des personnes
étrangères non mais donc voilà donc
c'est 14% vous avez dit donc il reste 86
sénat sur itélé transversaux ne sait
même pas les personnes qui ont appelé la
chaîne française et qui sont d'origine
immigrée mais quand bien même moi là je
vous parle de harcèlement de rue je vous
parle d'agressions dans la rue et je
suis désolé toutes les filles qui vivent
ça ils savent très bien de quoi je parle
et non mais non on va toutes les filles
elles ne devront pas que quand vous
parlez société holding non mais c'est
pas vrai vous pouvez mais non mais votre
discours c'est en gros en gros les yeux
dans les yeux je vous lis votre discours
sain les immigrés ont beaucoup plus de
chances de nous agresser que les
non-immigrés c7 vous pensez mais ça
c'est faux madame vous êtes en français
les lois de la république
on ne peut pas dire ça arrive à
l'exercice du ministère de l'intérieur
pas dire ça vous stigmatisez une partie
de la population au nom de vos idées
d'extrême droite c'est honteux
[Applaudissements]
bon sens et c'est normal que ça se
répète plus un même un voilà en allemand
ici personne ne doute jamais voilà du
témoignage de thaïs c'est pas ça voilà
si c'est vrai c'est là c'est celle après
oui mais il ya plein d'affaires
d'agressions de viol etc qui sont
commises par des personnes qui ne sont
pas d'origine maghrébine on en parle
parfois sur ce plateau et personne ne
dit ah bah encore un blanc encore voilà
donc cesser toutes ses faces génération
des pères du coup elle desquels des
sports un arabe mais c'est ce contre
quoi je me bats depuis sept ans oui des
almadies encore en arabe allah raciste l
année encore que là la dila tunisien non
mais ils disent ils c'est dur aussi
parce que du compagnon lui fait le
procès dans l'autre sens des cas une
agression ce qu'on dit jamais encore un
blanc encore un catholique en france est
en fait pour toi non mais il ya aussi
des agresseurs qui ne sont pas d'origine
maghrébine il faut le dire ses
traditions mais jamais on va on va taper
sur les victimes qu'encore moi la cause
toute la vérité quand leur allant leur
agresseur n'est pas le prétendu
patriarcat blanc moi je suis désolé
c'est pas le patriarcat blanc qui malgré
son mari